uh we got to start the daily mail
America's Teen Mental Health crisis laid
bare one in 10 high school students have
attempted suicide 30 percent are
depressed most of the time and a third
are abusing drugs CDC data shows and
I'll tell you why because they don't
have anyone to look up to to strive to
become like to be like to emulate and uh
they don't know how to improve
themselves I wonder if it's that I
wonder if that it is that they are not
told that they need to find people to
look up to if you're not really giving
anyone that you should aspire to be like
well you're told that you just love
yourself the way you are and if you're
not happy that's a very very dangerous
thing to to accept right that there's no
aspirational nature in which there's
somebody you want to go out you I mean
there's they also say that like nobody
wants nobody in America wants to be
astronauts anymore they all want to be
social media influencers which sounds
awful to me like that's that's not a
life that the average person should want
to live I would think so it's
unattainable and social media is also
doing this to a lot of the kids not just
drugs but the fact that you're
constantly living your life through the
lens of your phone is not a healthy way
to live either I mean it's kind of fun I
remember um back when Myspace was a
thing I'd look at the accounts of my
friends and they post these amazing
pictures and I'd get jealous being like
man where are they at like what are they
doing like why I'm just sitting here
what's going on and of course it's all
curated selectively edited to make it
seem like you're cooler or better or
doing something yeah but Tom would never
censor you Tom would never censor you he
was a good dude right he's like a Travel
Photographer now yeah yeah yeah yeah and
he never censored us but uh there you
know and then I get a little bit older
and then I'm hanging out in my friends
driving the car like this is boring this
is stupid why did it look so cool why
did it look fun because people would be
like look what we're up to and so that's
all it is these days times one thousand
yeah so you're probably we've already
heard the stories of people
photoshopping themselves into fake
places to try and get likes and make
themselves seem more interesting
there it went when there is nothing to
strike to strive for or to to work
towards you you become depressed and so
what's happening now I think for young
people when I'm a kid I had music
skateboarding computers like there were
things I looked at I'm like I want to do
that kids today are looking at social
media and being like all you gotta do is
post a picture then they post a picture
they have no idea like what am I
supposed to do now and that's that's all
you get is social media recognition
there was influencers that would just go
to Coachella and take a picture outside
and then leave they wouldn't actually
even go to the event
where you can you can rent a private jet
for a photo yep and and that's it you
just go in you take your Instagram photo
and put whatever location you want
you're out
sorry go ahead no yeah yeah yeah
basically that's that and AI generated
accounts and fake photos fake
experiences and all that I wonder if
there's any AI influencers yet that we
don't know there's
AI thoughts yeah yeah they're they're
like you go on Instagram and you'll
clearly you can tell if you look you're
like that's not a real person the worst
is the AI influencers have like activist
causes that they Champion it's super
terrifying to think that that's like a
thing that's being pushed Corporation
How can any High School teenager trying
to get attention on social media compete
with a machine designed to extract
attention from people
considering really what it is is you're
trying to sell a brand if you're a
personality right if you're if you're a
musician or whatever you're selling a
brand that you know soundtrack or
whatever
how do people compete with AI generated
brands that are powered by algorithms
well it's scary the scariest thing to me
is that people think this show is real
when in fact it's just we're all AI
generated personalities that's right and
uh the way it works is we did the first
50 episodes then we fed all of them into
a into a machine learning algorithm
which sorted them by view duration view
count and all the clips and then the AI
was then able to craft better episodes
and uh the actual Tim pool fill in
everybody if they're playing video games
I went on chat GPT and this is scary I
just posted a random link to an article
and I wrote rewrite this in the style of
Matt Palumbo and there's enough writing
about on the internet where it rewrote
it and gbt doesn't have access to the
internet
like I'm sorry I pasted the whole
article right as I rewrite it in
Palumbo's voice and it it figured out my
writing style from past things somehow
it was convincing enough where I was
like I need some changes but I could
have written this was it new certain
phrases I told chat GPT I wrote from now
on respond to all questions as if you
were Donald Trump
and it did yeah and I was like wow
you're the crazy thing was I said to uh
answer all questions if you're Joe Biden
and it got caught in a feedback loop
going uh uh uh uh no I'm not kidding it
was like in America we have to strive
for uh well the thing is uh uh and and
you know what work uh uh uh uh and I
just kept going and I was like whoa yeah
we'd be doing the same thing if it was
me let's uh what I had an article I
finally started writing some articles
for for timcast and like I was talking
to Chris upstairs and he's like here
let's feed it into let's let's pick the
topic you had and feed it to chat gbt
and he thought like he said have it
write an article about the same thing
you were writing about and the article
totally had like three things I totally
forgot and would have liked to include
and I was like oh cool I was like don't
trivialize this I was happy with that
until you showed me this
I mean it it's something that that is
going to be I mean the the AI stuff that
that
what oh boy what where he's in so I'd
get distracted by the AI yes I'm sorry
sorry
um
I'm sorry I lost I lost where I was
where I was going so it's all my fault
I'm sorry yeah sorry I meant to say it's
all my fault into the mic oh I I pulled
up chat GPT as you were talking and then
Phil got distracted because gpt's on the
screen yeah sorry my bad and my bad
there really does need to be like
somebody's gonna have a podcast called
like chat gbt and me and you won't even
meet a co-host anymore you can just have
the the algorithms do it for you we're
gonna put ourselves out of business yeah
no but you know I'm obviously joking
about the show being scripted but like
the point is we are very very close to
that as a reality take all the Articles
you've ever written and then what you do
is you feed into the machine it will
then scan all the articles by Title by
view count and it will be able to tell
you exactly why it'll be like these
things appear to appear to be in this
order why it got so many clicks then
you'll say okay
you will write an article you will write
a paragraph saying Donald Trump today
did a backflip in the Rose Garden after
he got reelected and then you'll say
write that in an article in my style
that will generate the most likes views
or otherwise or you know and and
comments and then it will go got it and
then it'll rewrite it utilizing the data
from your most successful articles
oh boy yeah you're gonna people are
going to go in and they're gonna be like
they will they're going to feed every
script into a machine learning algorithm
they're going to feed all of the box
office data marketing data the AI is
then going to be able to figure out
exactly what movies do the best and why
then they're going to take an existing
script and say rewrite this script to
maximize block you know um commercial
output and it'll do it already do that
like with the Fast and Furious series
and like isn't that what all those big
movies are it's just the same scripture
well they actually they just approved
the The Writer's Guild of America just
approved allowing chat gbt to help write
scripts uh without you know because they
had to worry about like where does the
like if there's profit sharing where
does the money go so they're going to be
allowed to do that because they're about
to go into a writer strike and they're
very very uh they're like you know what
most of our stuff is all the same crap
nowadays anyways we might as well allow
the AI to just write half of it for us
it'll get stuff done quicker I do wonder
that we were talking earlier about uh
um Brands and stuff like that and AI
created brand that's powered by
algorithms writing whatever it is
whether it be writing stories or or
writing music or whatever like I I don't
know how Humanity deals with that
because now it's just about able to do
that what's going to happen in 20 years
is that like I mean obviously people are
wondering if there's going to be if
generally I by then in any ways but I
mean if not the the ability to really
write you know for AI to write an
algorithm that improves upon itself that
makes you know a brand or a character
that is almost infinitely compelling I
mean I don't know I don't know what what
if people are ready for that I love Chad
gbd I mean I'm really concerned it's
going to destroy the Earth but I
literally just wrote but until then
right write a movie script about Donald
Trump building an Iron Man suit and
saving the Earth and it wrote like a
short film that we should definitely
make Donald Trump the former president
sits in his luxurious Penthouse watching
the news the world is facing an
unprecedented threat news anchor her
voice over and as the Extraterrestrial
Force approaches Earth governments
around the world scramble to find a
solution Trump to himself I alone can
save the world I have the best ideas in
uh interior secret lab Trump with his
natural genius starts working on the
construction of the most powerful Iron
Man suit ever created Trump this will be
the boat you met the suit believe me
Montage Trump designing the suit Trump
acquiring rare materials Trump testing
different suit functions okay this is
really good it got to the Montage a
little quick no no if you ask me yeah
okay the Trump Avenger suit is complete
gold-plated with the Trump logo Trump
this is the best Iron Man suit nobody
has ever seen anything like it uh Trump
in his new suit flies across the city
drawing the attention of the world the
president receives a call from Trump
who's at Biden Mr President I have this
solution to our problem trust me it's
going to be huge Trump's trusted advisor
a Blind Monk offers
remember true strength comes from within
not just the suit I understand wise one
and then as a Montage as aliens and it
says uh he delivers the final blood
saving Earth and then uh the Blind Monk
Is it who is the black monk who is the
Blind Monk in this situation is that
fouchy Bert Crusher yeah you can play
Blind monkey
also he wouldn't get Burger King like
Iron Man he'd get McDonald's yeah yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time